[Musik]
das ist jetzt die nadelwalze und das ist
ein geschlossenes Kugellager damit der
Dreck nicht reinkommt wenn man zum
Beispiel in deinem Mund auch so ein
kugellagerei machen oder kein Dreck mehr
rauskommen ja ja ich brauche eure Hilfe
mach du und zwar bin ich gerade am
Rezepte recherchieren und ich habe
gerade echt viel zu tun das dreht Team
wartet auch gerade in der Küche und mir
schon eingefahren in Schweden gibt's so
tolle Rezepte weißt du da gibt's die
Mittagspause wo sie sich einen Kaffee
treffen zusammenkommen Freunde Kollegen
Familie und jetzt so gern schwedische
Rezepte und eigentlich war es schon
immer ein Traummann nach Schweden zu
reisen aber ich dachte mir ich schaffe
das jetzt gerade nicht ich kann nicht
hier drehen und parallele Rezepte suchen
das wäre doch voll cool wenn ihr zwei so
einen Moment Trip macht und Freunde
trifft ihr zwei nach Schweden ihr holt
Rezeptideen ja wir waren schon mal
einkaufen
Aubergine äh Ding gebracht
schon lange nicht mehr zusammen Zeit
verbracht meine Freunde sind eine Woche
Schweden einfach paar Tage zusammen
verbringen Rezeptideen holen Spaß haben
Essen Trinken genießen ihr macht es
schon ich zähle auf euch okay ich gehe
weiter drehen mach andere Rezept und ihr
bringt mir coole Rezepte denn okay
früher
viel Spaß danke
[Musik]
oh mein Gott bin ich habe echt keine
Zeit ich muss den Rasen hier fertig
kriegen die Sonne kommt wieder raus aber
ich weiß
den Flug buchen machst du alles ja ich
habe keine Zeit für ihn bis dann ernst
ja
unsere zwei quatschköpfe auf großer
Mission Murat und Günni haben uns
letztes Jahr schon bewiesen dass sie
zusammen alles schaffen können
kannst du einfach
so super danke
schön
oh mein Gott nein doch komm komm dieses
Mal verschluckt es sie nach Schweden auf
der Suche nach neuen Rezepten am Ende
mit ihrer Auswahl aber zufrieden sein
wird kann nur sie wissen also liebe
Kinder schauen wir mal was die beiden
für ein Schabern in Stockholm werden
so ein geile Geschichte wir werden
unsicher machen ja
kein Stau ich freue mich richtig
kalt oh hast du -5 Grad
du verarschst mich doch gerade oder was
ist denn weißt du wo wir sind was wir
sind in Göteburg
wir wollten nach Stockholm was hast Du
gebucht wir haben Karte
im 21 Jahrhundert der hat noch eine
Karte
machen
lass uns jetzt kommen lassen Sie mich
jetzt ist es wie sie ist fertig
ja alles klar
[Musik]
das ist falsch rechts sag mal irgendwie
ich blick da nicht mehr durch die Karte
weg die Karte ist super du kannst nicht
lesen ja wirklich so super ab lass mich
fahren
du schläften kann ich ganz wenigstens
okay jetzt ist ganz wichtig murak wir
müssen rechts ab auf die Autobahn
Murat Mura ist das sorry tut mir leid
wirklich oh sorry ich hab's sorry
eine Stunde Umweg aber wir sind zusammen
das Schönste was es gibt und du sagst du
vielleicht besser
wir sitzen 23 jahrhundert ja
19:23er 2023 der benutzten heute noch
eine Karte wo hast du eigentlich
ausgegrenzt nein nämlich nicht wo sind
wir eigentlich jetzt gerade nach
Nordosten
wir sind jetzt zu jedem Camping vorbei
Museum kennhult ach Gott guck dir mal
das Ding an muss
ein bisschen Zeit wir können doch die
Rezepte noch später machen ja
noch offen nicht
nein scheiße
wir probieren es einfach so gut dass ich
an
sterbe okay pass auf das ist der
Husqvarna an das ist ein Fluss und zwar
der fließt durch Husqvarna und Husqvarna
ist diese Marke
verstehst Geschwindigkeit
und zwar Folgen
Museum ist war früher die Waffenfabrik
hier war die Mühle und die haben sie das
Wasser und die Energie benutzt um die
Waffen die Gewehre herzustellen
Wasserkraft genau das heißt Husqvarna
die Firma ist über 333 Jahre alt laut
Adam Riese
ja hatten die
hahaha
[Musik]
fast einfach nichts an okay ich habe
keinen Bock da rausgeschmissen zu werden
und haben auch keine Lust das sind alles
verwiesen werden
für Deutschland
also von 1689 bis
[Applaus]
1872 fast 200 Jahre lang haben sie
Langwaffen produziert für nur
lang machen
schon früh
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
als 1872 die Produktion von Waffen zum
Erliegen kam hat Husqvarna Nähmaschine
hergestellt Medizintechnik
Öfen Fahrräder Motorräder und Backöfen
also backöfen und Herde von Husqvarna
gibt es heute in Schweden immer noch das
waren Joyce Venture damals mit
Elektrolux und wirklich alles im
Küchenbereich das heißt wirklich auch
von Gusseisen und Eisenpfannen auch
Husqvarna bulanz zum Beispiel
Grillpfanne und das gab es alles von
Husqvarna das ist auch genial ich finde
das Design auch wahnsinnig guck mal
richtig cool tut es eigentlich weh
zumindest ins Gesicht bekommt ja
[Musik]
die meisten von euch ist wahrscheinlich
Husqvarna ein Begriff aus dem Garten
weil auch den Garten haben so krass dass
sie nie aufgehört haben sich weiter zu
entwickeln hier zum Beispiel das ist
wirklich der erste Automobil der voll
elektrische Rasenmäher Roboter dann
haben sie 1995 entwickelt der ist
komplett Solar Betrieben der hat sich
selber aufgeladen und das war wirklich
das ist das Produkt Nummer 1 und damit
haben
Welt erobern heutzutage ist Husqvarna
der Weltmarktführer für autonomes nee
sozusagen weißt du dass ich
Husqvarna heißt
[Gelächter]
vor dem ihr müsst ihr keine Angst haben
vor dem hier schon und zwar macht dieses
Ding hier bis zu 5000 Quadratmetern
Begrenzungskabel und es gibt inzwischen
schon Husqvarna Mähroboter die schaffen
bis zu 70.000 Quadratmetern unglaublich
oder neben dem Hauptgeschäftsfeld Garten
ist ein Hauptgeschäftsfeld von Husqvarna
und dafür auch weltweit bekannt die
Forstwirtschaft und die werden übrigens
noch hier in Schweden produziert und
zwar auch direkt hier im Werk in
Husqvarna hier werden sie wirklich per
Hand mal schnell und teilautomatisiert
produziert aber dazu gehen wir glaube
ich lieber mal ins Werk und ich zeige
euch mal wer diese Maschinen macht und
wo sie gemacht werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier in diesem Standort tun sie über 40
verschiedene kettensägenmodelle
produzieren egal ob Elektro oder
Benziner jeden Tag verlassen 3 bis 4000
hätten Siegen den Ort hier und werden
dann weltweit verschifft und verschickt
ich bin so unglaublich wie ein Buch
Wahnsinn guck mal der macht jetzt alles
per Hand hier unten
unglaublich
schon drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier sind die ganzen Förderbänder und
jetzt weiß jeder was er machen muss ich
muss jetzt hier zum Beispiel eine
Schraube rein machen und
oh mein Gott
okay
einer Maschine etwas fehlt weil ich
gerade zu langsam war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guck mal siehst du hier ist die erste
Kettensäge schon fertig aber wenn der
Body fertig ist wird sie komplett hier
noch mal getestet das heißt jede
Maschine es gibt keinen Spaß mit einmal
mit 13.000 Umdrehungen getestet das
heißt es wird gezogen hier und der ganze
Funktionstest gemacht sorry
ist okay
[Musik]
hier ist eine Halle hier werden komplett
alle Maschinen verpackt also wirklich
eine komplette Halle nur mit Verpackung
hier sieht man z.B ein Trennjäger hier
wird gerade dieser Trennjäger selber
schon gearbeitet habe das nicht verpackt
auf Paletten und geht dann geht's
überall raus in die Welt hast gesehen
wie cool das gemacht
bin verblüfft
das Navi Roboter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so dann lassen wir Murat und König die
Kettensägen die sie eben noch im Werk
bestaunt haben ausprobieren warte mal
hey wer gibt den gerade so eine
unverhältnismäßig cooles Logo
[Musik]
bitte ich kann nicht übertragen
hast okay also Fuß rein ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
natürlich kann ich es auch ich habe
vorhin schon diesen Bär hier geschnitten
mit meiner Säge
unglaubliche das habe ich jetzt
innerhalb von drei Minuten habe ich
diesen Bär gemacht wenn wir zum Beispiel
so kleine Äste hat kann man hier diese
Habibi Säge nehmen dass die s-feier das
cool ist auch ein Akku und der
funktioniert auf Bosch Geräte Ziel ist
wenn man zu Hause
jetzt kann man die laufen lassen ganz
wichtig mit zwei hätten benutzen nicht
rumfuchteln und dann hier so gesehen
Schutz
okay
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was auch ganz cool ist bei der Serie ist
wenn wir z.B zu Hause hohe Obstbäume hat
oder mal was ganz weit oben abschneiden
muss und dann natürlich sicher stehen
möchte und nicht auf den Baum klettern
muss dann macht man einfach hier die
Teleskopstange kann die Höhe wirklich
einstellen so festmachen
Schutz runter und einfach von hier unten
starten
[Musik]
bewegt sich nicht bleibt bitte genauso
wie du bist bitte ja was machst du nicht
sprechen
für dich wenn du mein Freund bist so
hässlich
großes Maul
[Musik]
oh mir ist voll kalt und außerdem habe
ich richtig Hunger ehrlich
noch kurz reingehen
wir fallen auf hier glaube ich
[Musik]
das war 70% Steigung und das schafft
hier der
435x AWD AWD heißt all wheelsdrive und
ist ein Allradantrieb hier durch das
Knickgelenk ist ja auch sehr sehr
flexibel und er schafft
3.500 Quadratmetern
alles was orange ist an dem Gerät das
nicht Funktion hat zum Beispiel hier
drücken ziehen und wie auch immer und
ist eine Heckenschere das Besondere an
diese heckenscheres ist diese Sinne das
hat nämlich eine normale Heckenschere
nicht dass Du hier diese Erhöhung hast
das heißt wenn du mit der Heckenschere
schneidest ich kenne selber das z.B das
ganze Schnitt gut dann wirklich in den
Strauch reinfällt und hier ist es so man
kann den Strauch oder die Hecke wirklich
so durchkämmen hier bleibt der Schnitt
gut hängen und fliegt dann auf dem Boden
und hier haben wir den Rasenmäher der
Aspire Serie ich kenne das Problem
gerade in der Garage oder im
Gartenhäuschen egal im Haus hat ein
bisschen wenig Platz und der lässt sich
richtig cool zusammenfalten
hier das Ärmchen runter so und jetzt
hier umklappen den Fangkorb nehmen den
tankkorb kann man hier oben einklemmen
auch richtig cool so und jetzt kann man
einfach an der Wand festmachen einfach
platzsparen und wohin hängen richtig
cool oder das ist der Akku Trimmer der
Aspire Serie hier zum Beispiel
Teleskopstange immer verstellen kann
oder hier auch den Haltegriff hier kann
man z.B den Winkel auch mit drauf
drücken komplett den Winkel verstellen
Husqvarna stell hier in Schweden
wirklich absolute Qualität her und das
schon seit Jahren und ich finde die
machen richtig tolle Produkt
wir verlosen jedes Produkt der Aspire
Serie einmal ihr habt jetzt alle die
einzigartige Möglichkeit hier einer
diese Produkte zu gewinnen dafür müsste
eigentlich nur in die Kommentare
reinschreiben welches Produkt ihr gerne
hättet möchtet ihr vielleicht den
Rasenmäher den Rasentrimmer den
Laubbläser oder den Automobile schreibt
es in die Kommentare was ihr trinken
könnt vielleicht vielleicht habt ihr
auch ein paar Bäume bei euch im Garten
und könnt die Astsäge richtig toll
gebrauchen schreibt es in die Kommentare
was ihr haben möchtet und wir schicken
es euch einfach zu vielen vielen Dank
hier auch an Husqvarna die uns die
Möglichkeit gegeben haben dass hier
alles zu verlosen äh will ich eine tolle
Geschichte ja
welches Gerät würdest du hier nehmen
soll mal ganz ehrlich welches bist du
ganz ganz dringend gebrauchen ich kann
sie entscheiden ja glaube ich dir
ausgenommen ist natürlich Mitarbeiter
von Husqvarna und
Günni natürlich auch also könnt ihr alle
mitmachen wir machen okay alles klar
[Musik]
weißt du was ich voll schön finde ja
dass wir hier in der schwedischen Natur
so zusammen weißt du und ich wir sind so
Freunde in unserem Leben schon so viel
erlebt wir sind in der Türkei gewesen am
Trüffel gesammelt jetzt immer sind wir
in Schweden wir waren bei Husqvarna
zusammen wir erfüllen unsere Träume das
ist wichtig im Leben es gibt nämlich
nichts wichtiger ja und du sitzt
doch nicht wichtig für das was wir
erleben Geld ist noch 2 Wochen aber die
Liebe
verarschen ja
übrigens gerade machen das nennt sich
eine schwedische [__] du bist aber
nicht sexistisch oder nein nein nein
wirklich so das schwedische [__]
heißen nein auch ja was
Mittagspause und zwar eine Kaffee und
eine Teepause
und da kriegt man Kaffee und Tee und
dann haben wir hier z.B was ich habe dir
schon was vorbereitet und zwar Semmler
ja und zwar ist es eine Mantel Creme
guck mal Holzspäne noch dran
ich habe das für dich gemacht weil du
mein bester Freund bist
[Musik]
schmeckt gut
aber schmeckt richtig lecker
[Musik]
der größte der zweitgröße sie von
Schweden der ist eine Länge 135 km lang
und 500 m breit
voll gehauen verstehen dass ich meine
haben das gemacht was uns Spaß macht und
meine Frau vergessen es gibt richtig
Ärger ich glaube wir sollten Autos
setzen und Richtung Stockholm fahren
oder dass man da irgendwo Rezepte kriege
ich glaube da gibt's die tollsten
Bäckerei und da können wir nach Rezepten
gucken
jetzt losfahren genieße noch mal 10
Minuten mal schön die Aussicht okay
unser Moment lass mal alles Revue
passieren
[Gelächter]
das war sie nun die abenteuerliche Reise
von Murat und Günni durch Schweden nach
dieser Reise verbindet Murat und Günni
jetzt definitiv mehr als nur ihre
Freundschaft also Husqvarna verbindet
sie auch noch was habt ihr denn gedacht
ich frag mich wo ist das nächste mal
wohin verschlägt ähm na ja das schauen
wir dann und wenn sie nicht gestorben
sind dann leben sie nach egal das ist
doch kein Märchen tschüss liebe Grüße
von Murat und Günni tschüss
[Musik]